de lo que quiero platicar en este vídeo
es acerca de la primera ley de newton
sobre el movimiento y este es una
traducción que encontré del libro
principio de newton y que se tradujo del
latín al español entonces esto de aquí
es la traducción de la primera ley de
newton que dice todo cuerpo persevera en
su estado de reposo en su estado de
reposo o de movimiento uniforme y
rectilíneo 'nos a no ser que sea
obligado a cambiar su estado por fuerzas
impresas sobre él es decir bueno lo que
nos está diciendo es imagínate cualquier
cuerpo cualquier objeto que se encuentre
en algún estado de reposo es decir que
no se mueva o que se encuentre moviendo
de digamos en línea recta y con
velocidad constante entonces va a
permanecer de esa forma a menos de que
algo externo a ese objeto le imprima una
fuerza para que desvíe su ruta o cambie
de por ejemplo si estaba en reposo y le
imprime una fuerza pues a lo mejor se
empieza a mover
mejor si se está moviendo y le imprime
una fuerza pues se detiene verdad
entonces no sé digamos es la primera
parte es muy fácil de entender digamos
que tenemos por ejemplo una piedra
digamos que tengo aquí una una roca una
piedra que importa
déjenme ponerle un poco más arriba
digamos que tengo aquí mi piedra y esta
piedra está parada en no sé digamos que
está en el campo donde aquí hay pasto
aunque hay entonces aquí hay pasto y ahí
está nuestra piedra entonces el primer
ejemplo o el o digamos la primera frase
o digamos la primera parte del enunciado
de la primera ley es muy obvio dice si
tenemos un cuerpo que se encuentre en
estado de reposo entonces va a
permanecer en estado de reposo a no ser
que sea obligado a cambiar su estado por
fuerzas impresas sobre él y en algunos
lados la definición dice que se le
impriman fuerzas desbalanceadas y ya
platicaremos de qué significa eso pero
si esta piedra por ejemplo se encuentra
en estado de reposo es decir no se mueve
entonces si nadie le aplica una fuerza
externa a esta piedra la vamos a seguir
viendo allí por el resto de los siglos y
quizás antes de seguir debería
presentarles realmente quiénes newton y
aquí tenemos a sir isaac newton que fue
físico matemático y que trabajó
justamente todo este tipo de cuestiones
del movimiento y ustedes se preguntarán
bueno y quién es este señor que está
aquí en una imagen muy grande en
realidad lo puse en una imagen muy
grande porque en el newton tomó la
primera ley y en realidad lo que planteo
newton es una un digamos parafraseó lo
que ya había estipulado galileo galileo
galilei como la ley de la inercia muy
bien entonces la primera ley de newton
en realidad sólo es una versión más más
moderna de lo que ya había dicho galileo
en la ley de la inercia y donde dice que
justamente los cuerpos se permanecen en
reposo o en movimiento rectilíneo
uniforme a menos de que haya una fuerza
desbalanceada que actúe sobre él y
cuando digo
es balanceada en realidad me refiero a
lo siguiente imaginemos esta misma
piedra que le aplicamos una fuerza de
este lado y supongamos que le aplicamos
la misma fuerza de este lado en sentido
contrario entonces si le aplicamos estas
dos fuerzas en realidad la piedra no se
va a mover les digamos que estamos como
que neutralizando esas fuerzas sin
embargo la definición
digamos considerando fuerzas
desbalanceadas me diría imagina que tú
ahora le pones una fuerza extra digamos
de no sé
quizás deberíamos considerar mejor un
ejemplo con hielo sería un poquito más
más intuitivo entonces imagínense que
tienen aquí digamos hielo que esto es
hielo y aquí encima de ese hielo tenemos
un cubo de hielo que no sé cómo de estos
que salen del refrigerador entonces aquí
tienen un cubito de hielo que está sobre
una superficie de hielo entonces si
nosotros le aplicamos una fuerza externa
de este lado y le aplicamos otra
idéntica de este otro lado pero en
sentido contrario el hielo no se va a
mover sin embargo si le aplicamos una
fuerza aunque sea pequeñita de este otro
lado el hielo inmediatamente va a
empezar a moverse en esta dirección
justamente porque ya las fuerzas son
desbalanceadas así que yo creo que esta
primera parte es bastante obvia la que
no es obvia es la siguiente nos dice que
ahora si uno nos diría todo cuerpo
persevera
un estado de movimiento uniforme y
rectilíneo o movimiento rectilíneo
uniforme a no ser que sea obligado a
cambiar su estado por fuerzas impresas
sobre el está esta frase ya no es tan
obvia por ejemplo
en realidad esto es una forma un poquito
más complicada de decir que nuestro
nuestro objeto se está moviendo con
velocidad constante muy bien entonces
esto ya no es tan obvio y no es tan
obvio porque un uno siempre pensaría que
bueno si yo empujo miguelito y se va
moviendo pues eventualmente se va a
detener verdad o por ejemplo no sé si si
si estamos jugando con alguna pelota
digamos una pelota algo así y nosotros
aumentamos esta pelota pues uno no
esperaría que esta pelota se vaya por el
resto de los siglos moviendo hacia
adelante sino 1-1 eventualmente ve que
la pelota se cae al suelo y una vez que
cae al suelo pues uno no la ve rodando
por el resto de los siglos entonces esto
es bastante o más bien es poco intuitivo
pero en realidad si tiene una
justificación
y bueno por ejemplo no sé si uno está
manejando un carro pues uno no esperaría
que tan solo de encenderlo y pisar el
acelerar el acelerador perdón uno
llegaría hasta cierta ciudad sin meterle
más fuerza uno tiene que estar y tiene
que realizar combustión todo el motor y
demás para poder seguir avanzando
entonces la explicación de por qué esto
se detiene es porque al final de cuentas
aunque haya muy poca fricción siempre
hay fricción con las dos superficies que
es lo que está pasando digamos que aquí
tenemos el arreglo de digamos en forma
de lápiz de nuestro cubito de hielo ok
aquí está el arreglo de las moléculas y
por acá abajo está el otro arreglo de
nuestra superficie de hielo
entonces cuando nuestro nuestro delito
se empieza a mover hacia la derecha este
estos dos arreglos empiezan a chocar y
al chocar pierden energía y desprenden
incluso calor y eso va generando una
fuerza que detiene este cubito de hielo
por ejemplo lo mismo ocurre con esta
pelota entonces claramente en algún
momento esta pelota llega al suelo
digamos aquí ya está en el suelo y pues
mucho más se va a detener si hay pasto
entonces el detalle es que cuando uno
avienta la pelota en realidad hay muchas
moléculas de aire que están ejerciendo
cierta fuerza sobre la pelota estas
moléculas están teniendo una fuerza que
va en contra del movimiento sobre la
pelota y eso provoca que eventualmente
se detenga por supuesto cuando ya llegó
al suelo pues el mismo pasto o el suelo
imprime una fuerza de fricción que hace
que se detenga verdad que impide el
movimiento
lo mismo ocurre con el con el hielo si
nosotros no vemos el hielo también va a
haber moléculas de aire que están
ejerciendo una fuerza en contra del
movimiento sobre el hielo así que lo
verdaderamente brillante de estos
personajes es que pudieron imaginar un
mundo o más bien una realidad en donde
por ejemplo no hubiera aire que no
hubieran fuerzas de fricción y que no
hubiera gravedad y allí es en donde las
cosas en esa realidad allí es en donde
las cosas permanecen en su estado de
reposo o de movimiento rectilíneo
uniforme a menos de que algo más que sea
externo a estos objetos le imprima una
fuerza muy bien que lo saque de ese de
ese estado y yo creo que galileo tuvo
ese pensamiento o pudo llegar a ese tipo
de conclusiones porque galileo estaba
estudiando el movimiento de las órbitas
de los planetas y ahí así al final de
cuentas pues los planetas no dejan de
moverse verdad
quizás quizás galileo pudo pudo
interpretar que en ese espacio en el
espacio donde se mueven los planetas ahí
puede ser que no hubiera fricción puede
ser que no hubiera aire y entonces eso
explicaría por qué los planetas no dejan
de moverse verdad como nuestra pelotita
que lanzamos entonces espero que hayas
encontrado esto realmente fascinante
tanto como yo porque hasta cierto nivel
es muy obvio por ejemplo el ejemplo
bueno más el ejemplo de la roca pero por
el otro no lo es verdad y sólo para
dejar esto claro digamos el ejemplo este
de la pelota verdad vamos a retomar el
ejemplo de la pelota
en el ejemplo de la pelota si no hubiera
aire si no hubiera gravedad si no
hubiera fricción al lanzar nosotros esta
pelota la pelota seguiría en su
movimiento rectilíneo uniforme a menos
de que algo más la detenga verdad eso sí
no existieran todas esas todas estas
condiciones
y solo para dejar también muy claro esto
vamos a vamos a ver un ejemplo más
cotidiano imaginemos que estamos en un
avión
tienen ustedes un avión
más o menos
ahí tienen ustedes un avión y digamos
que en este avión se encuentran ustedes
adentro pero este avión no tiene
ventanas de tal suerte que ustedes no
pueden ver hacia afuera y tampoco pueden
digamos que ustedes no escuchan ningún
ruido entonces no pueden saber si la
maquinaria que mueve el avión está
encendida o apagada aunque imaginemos
también que mientras va volando no hay
turbulencia entonces este ejemplo es es
muy interesante porque si el si el avión
se mueve a velocidad constante constante
que de hecho es otra forma de decir esto
verdad el movimiento uniforme y
rectilíneo decir esto es lo mismo que
decir que vamos con una velocidad
constante velocidad
constante verdad si ustedes se
encuentran en este avión ficticio sin
ruido sin turbulencia sin ventanas
entonces ustedes no pueden determinar si
el avión se está moviendo o si está en
reposo verdad si ustedes van en ese
avión pues ustedes van a sentir que no
se mueven estando en ese marco de
referencia entonces realmente del
movimiento rectilíneo uniforme al reposo
es bastante ambiguo en esos casos no
puedes determinar cuál es cuál cuando
tienes esas condiciones